New research shows that it's definitely better
to make love not war.
Hey I'm Carin for DNews and today we've got
a story about the evolution of cooperation.
To get a better understanding of this idea,
researchers from Emory University looked at
spontaneous cooperation in a population of
eleven chimpanzees.
Here's what they did.
The chimps were housed in a large outdoor
enclosure.
This kind of complex environment is far different
than the simple setups normally used when
testing social behavior in primates - and
this is significant because it more closely
resembles the chimps' natural setting.
Researchers rigged up an experimental apparatus
that required either one or two chimps to
move a barrier while another pulled in a tray
that was baited with food.
That meant that the task could not be completed
by one individual alone.
Researchers undertook a large scale set of
observations on how the chimps handled the
task at hand, and they found that they spontaneously
cooperated more than 35-hundred times over
almost a hundred hour-long sessions.
Interestingly, it turned out that an individual
chimpanzee was more likely to lend a helping
hand when another chimp of a similar rank
was around.
And it didn't seem to matter to the chimps
whether they were related or not - the most
important factor was social status.
The researchers say this shows that chimps
have a direct preference for cooperating with
socially tolerant partners - AND they're able
to do this spontaneously in a complex environment.
Similar studies have been done before, in
much more controlled settings.
But the high level of cooperation exhibited
in this study wasn't thought to exist in chimps.
Last week my buddy Trace brought you a story
about how the facial features of human males
may have evolved due to the fact that we hit
each other a lot; however, this week's story
gives us a different perspective on the evolution
of our social behavior.
What it tells us is that spontaneous cooperation
between individuals DOES happen in a natural
setting.
However, the fact that social rank played
such a large role in whether the chimps cooperated
also tells us that there could easily be violent
clashes between individuals of different social
status.
Researchers still have a lot more to learn
about the similarities between chimps' and
humans' behavior.
But since they're our closest primate relatives,
this work is still really exciting because
it sheds important light on the evolution
of cooperation in us as well.
So does this study make you feel a little
better about humanity?
Let us know in the comments below and keep
coming back for more DNews every day of the
week.